hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet in this little clip you're
about to hear a conversation that i had
with bobby seagull who's the author of
the life changing magic numbers the monk
woman single quiz book and it's like a
national celebrity here in the uk around
maths and the idea of achievement and
we're talking about tips on how you can
boost your motivation permanently like
what are the things that we can change
about our environment the people we hang
out with that our information diet to
permanently raise our aspirations in a
way that encourages us to be more
intentional about the goals we're
setting and how we're going after them
and i think it's just a place where
i think there were no limits on
capability or your achievement because
although again my secondary school was a
very good one in the borough and i would
always i'm actually sometimes people
when they've achieved they'll often go
back and say oh i grew up in a really
you know in a terrible counter state and
my secondary school was terrible no one
achieved actually our school uh
definitely said you can achieve but
again but again in an environment where
not many people go on to the top
universities um it can still limit your
ambitions i remember one of my secondary
teachers in fact i sort of kept in touch
with him
he was telling me bobby the maximum you
can get is 5a stars in the school maybe
you can be a dentist but you know don't
aim more than that and he was a get too
honest he was a teacher that believed in
us in my state school but when he went
to eaton suddenly they're like oh you
can find your own business you can be
the prime minister you can be the
best-selling author you can be a famous
hollywood actor
there was no limit to the sort of
achievement okay that you could and does
that make a difference to like
your psychology i guess i think it's
i think humans we can be our own worst
enemies we can set ourselves barriers
before society does because sometimes
people say oh it's my friends my family
society they say i can't achieve
x y or zed but actually i think we can
be we can internalize that and say
actually because of those
influences actually i shouldn't aim to
go to a good university i shouldn't
think about oxbridge i shouldn't aim for
a career a conventional career in the
city i shouldn't try and become a doctor
so i think we internalize
almost like the success of people around
us yeah and there's like i don't know
who's said this concept but i almost
think that we average
the experiences and
motivations of people around us so if
people that you spend your time with are
very negative very moody have low
self-esteem we naturally average out
let's say the five closest people and we
have we take on that sort of the same
traits we we take on low self-esteem we
take on a low view of ourselves but if
you're around people that think that the
sky is the limit actually then okay
maybe you're not going to end up have it
reaching the sky but you will raise your
aspiration
so i yeah i i fully agree with this and
there's a lot of stuff that people like
gary vaynerchuk talk about as well where
um
you know
one
one thing one thing i strongly feel is
that like even if even if you can't
change the environment around you or the
people around you you can for example
change
what you watch on youtube or what
podcast you listen to or what books you
read or whatever and
for someone for example you know just to
use a very a trivial example like for
most people the idea of starting a
youtube channel or going on university
challenge or writing a book these are
pretty weird things to do but if you're
listening to podcasts where which is
interviewing the top 500 people who ever
went on university challenge suddenly
it's like oh actually this is this is
fairly doable if you listen to podcasts
where everyone being interviewed as an
entrepreneur or a creator suddenly it
kind of expands your box
and it kind of makes oh actually that
that thing seems more doable i remember
this happened for me when there's a guy
called ralph potts who's got a a podcast
where he talks about long-term travel
with various people you know people who
have traveled around the world with just
a backpack people who've traveled around
the world with nothing at all uh men
women all walks of life and in my head i
always thought oh travel equals
dangerous equals hardy was bad but just
hearing all these interviews made me
think oh actually this is this is quite
doable um so i'm i'm a very strong
believer in the idea that like if you
change the if you change the stuff that
you're being fed like informationally
whether it's for the people around you
or the stuff that you consume it does
have the power to just change the way
that you see things hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day